so joe biden's uh reported nominee for
this very important post in the doj
holds a ton of extremely racist ugly
views
similar views being held apparently by
joe biden's
choice for deputy education secretary
so joe biden announced that he he wanted
to pick
the san diego unified school district
superintendent cindy martin
for deputy secretary of education
secretary of education what what does
the education department even do
i guess not all they don't they're not
empowered to do all that much
by the law or you know this obviously
doesn't appear anywhere in the
constitution
but they do have quite a lot of power to
craft the direction of curriculum in the
united states one way they do this
is through things like dear colleague
letters
basically strong recommendations from
the federal government
that you know if you want to keep
getting your money if you want to keep
getting all these goodies from the
federal government you have to do what
we want you to do
on various sort of social engineering
policies
the famous dear colleague letter from
the obama administration had to do with
transgender ideology well here this
person who biden wants for deputy
education secretary
holds very racist views she's a white
lady but she holds these very
sort of what do you call it
i guess black racialist views the same
kinds of things
that we have just been talking about so
she believes that
schools quote spirit murder
black children and what that white
teachers should
should undergo quote anti-racist therapy
anti-racist therapy so you've got now
the announced biden pick
for deputy education secretary calling
for
the reprogramming only of
white teachers who are not
anti-racist enough meaning they they
could be not racist but that's not
enough you've got to be anti-racist
meaning you've got to be racist
[Music]
the teachers are are not uh focused
enough
on how terrible the scourge of white
supremacy is
and how schools quote spirit murder
black children whatever that means
and so they've got to go to re-education
camps that's not even
just being reported that has been
announced
moving over to the department of health
and human services
i've got to be very very careful with
this one because i think we could all be
censored for this
and there are major calls right now for
conservatives to be censored so i'm just
going to present the facts
okay and you tell me if something seems
a little strange
joe biden has selected the pennsylvania
health secretary
dr rachel levine to be
assistant secretary of health and human
services
dr rachel levine that was not his
given name when he was born dr rachel
levine
is a man who thinks that he's a woman
he's being nominated to be the assistant
secretary of health
and human services
a man who is
under the impression that he is a woman
in some deep metaphysical way
that his true identity as a woman even
though all of the characteristics that
he has
are man manly masculine
uh he is now to be the assistant
secretary of health and human services
does that seem a little strange to you
that seems a little strange to me i'm
i don't i don't want to step out of line
i don't want to
uh seems a little strange doesn't it
but it doesn't but it doesn't it only
seems strange
to people with even a modicum of common
sense left
because we are
back into the normal scope of this
liberal political regime and the normal
kinds of politics that we see here
that's not normal compared to objective
standards that's not normal compared to
historical
norms you know moving back
decades and decades but it is normal
today
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you